j'habite juste en rêvait depuis un peu
plus de 8 ans j'ai créé ma boîte ce dans
la foulée et depuis cette époque j'ai 13
ans veille sur ce qui se passe sur le
plateau de saclay notamment du point de
vue de grandes promesses pareil ça
clairement j'ai toujours entendu parler
et quand
le proto 204 a ouvert j'ai pensé que
peut-être c'était ma chance et la
première fois que quelque chose de
véritables se passe sur plateau de
saclay qui puisse vraiment faire se
rencontrer tous les publics du plateau
puisque mon expérience du plateau c'est
que on y est très bien mais on y est
d'autant mieux qu'on participe à un
groupe qui est celui des écoles ou celui
des grandes entreprises ou celui du
campus mais ces publics là ne se croise
pas du tout et les habitants qui n'ont
pas de rapport avec le monde
scientifique encore moins donc j'étais
très très en attente à la fin comme
habitante et comme entreprise de trouver
un lieu où enfin je puisse rencontrer
les centres gens du plateau en
s'investissant et en venant
régulièrement la fois comme auditeur des
événements et petit à petit comme acteur
et porteurs de projets à soi même et se
passait ses rencontres extraordinaires
on apprend on découvre on s'enrichit et
on enrichit aussi son carnet d'adressés
voulu rendre sa très concret moi-même
monde venant porteurs de projets sur du
réseautage intelligents au proto 204 non
cloisonné où sur un projet qui s'appelle
my bézy mille j'organise ce qui peut
s'apparenter à des repas d'affaires au
proto 204 ou des pros porteurs de
projets salariés entrepreneurs
et puis personnel du campus peuvent
rejoindre sur l'heure du déjeuner 12h
14h au proto un groupe qui fait de la co
création de contenu en même temps qu'il
est jeune donc on est sur un temps
obligatoire pour manger et en même temps
ça entendre au poète et tente et on met
à profit pour rencontrer les autres et
tous ces autres du plateau qui sont
généralement plutôt cachée plutôt isolé
chacun dans leur branche
donc c'est totalement l'esprit proto se
rencontrer faire
être soi-même dans l'apport de quelque
chose et recevoir des autres et
construire ensemble